FEDERAL LAWS AND STOP THE CRISIS
AT THE BORDER.
VALVERDE COUNTY COMMISSIONER BO
IS LEADING THE EFFORT TO JOIN
FORCES WITH HIS FELLOW BORDER
COMMUNITY.
HE JOINS US NOW FROM DEL RIO,
TEXAS.
BO, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, HOW ARE YOU
DOING TODAY?
STEVE: WE ARE DOING OKAY.
WE ARE DOING BETTER THAN YOU
ARE.
YOU WAS A CRISIS ON YOUR HAND
ALTHOUGH THE ADMINISTRATION
WON’T CALL IT THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
SUPPOSED TO DO IS SUPPOSED TO
PROVIDE THE NATIONAL DEFENSE.
IS THE FACT THAT THEY ARE NOT
ENFORCING OUR SOUTHERN BORDER,
ISN’T THAT A VIOLATION -- AREN’T
THEY JUST LETTING PEOPLE IN?
ISN’T THIS A NATIONAL SECURITY
PROBLEM?
>> THIS IS A HUGE NATIONAL
SECURITY PROBLEM.
I MEAN, WE HAVE PEOPLE CROSSING
THIS BORDER AND WE HEARD NUMBERS
OF THIS GROUP UP TO 20,000 AND
WE HAVE HAD THOUSANDS BEFORE
THIS.
AND THEN THAT DOESN’T EVEN
INCLUDE THE FACT THAT WHILE OUR
IMMIGRATION OFFICERS AND DPS AND
EVERYBODY IS BUSY DEALING WITH
LARGE CROWDS.
WE STILL HAVE HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
GOING AROUND THESE COMMUNITIES,
OUT THROUGH THESE RURAL AREAS
WITH DRUGS AND SMUGGLING AND ALL
KINDS OF OTHER STUFF AND WE
DON’T EVEN KNOW SOME COUNTRIES
THAT THEY ARE COMING FROM.
NOT INCLUDING ALL THE DISEASES
THAT ARE COMING, WITH COVID AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
INTREASH EXPLAIN HOW IT WORKS IN
YOUR COUNTY.
UNDER THE BRIDGE IN DEL RIO,
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR THE BORDER
PATROL PERSON TO SURRENDER TO TO
BE PUT IN THE SYSTEM.
IS THAT HOW IT GENERALLY WORKS
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY
FROM BORDER PATROL OR ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF GOT-AWAYS
WHO DO NOT WANT TO ENCOURT THEM
BECAUSE THEY HAVE GOT DRUGS OR
HEAVEN TO BETSY WHO KNOWS WHAT?
HAITIANS LOOKING FOR BORDER
PATROL TO GIVE UP TO ALLOW THEM
IN THE COUNTRY.
OTHER GROUPS OUT THERE DON’T
WANT TO BE CAUGHT BECAUSE
THEY’RE HAULING DRUGS AND
FENTANYL AND DIFFERENT TYPES OF
THINGS AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND, GOD KNOWS WHAT ELSE IS
GOING OUT THERE.
AND BORDER PATROL MEN SO TIED UP
WITH LARGE GROUPS TRYING TO
PROCESS THEM AND DEAL WITH THEM
THEY DON’T HAVE TIME TO BE OUT
IN THE FIELD TO DEAL WITH THE
OTHER ISSUES.
STEVE: SURE, BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL NOT, YOU KNOW,
KEEP OUR SOUTHERN BORDER STRONG,
THE MIGRANTS ARE COMING IN TO
YOUR COUNTY.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT IS REALLY
SAPPING YOUR COMMUNITY SERVICES.
YOU KNOW, IF THEY PARK IN YOUR
COUNTY FOR A WHILE, THEY ARE
GOING TO NEED STUFF.
>> IT IS.
I MEAN, WE HAVE, YOU KNOW,
BORDER PATROL PICKS UP GROUPS
AND THEN THEY RELEASE THEM INTO
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR NGO HAS
TO DEAL WITH IT WE ARE A SMALL
COMMUNITY.
THIS COUNTY IS ABOUT 49,000
PEOPLE.
WE DON’T HAVE THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MOVE PEOPLE
OUT OF HERE LIKE YOU SEE IN THE
LARGER CITIES, SO, PEOPLE WILL
GET STUCK HERE WAITING DAYS AND
DAYS AND DAYS FOR A BUS TO BE
ABLE TO LEAVE THE COMMUNITY AND
GO WHEREVER IT IS THAT THEY’RE
HEADED.
AND IT PUTS A BIG BURDEN.
YOU KNOW, AS OF RIGHT NOW, I
THINK OUR COUNTY HAS SPENT
PROBABLY $400,000 DEALING WITH
THEIR WHICH DOESN’T SEEM LIKE A
LOT OF MONEY TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
BUT WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A
COMMUNITY OF THIS SIZE, 400,000S
DOLLARS IS A LOT OF MONEY.
THAT DOESN’T INCLUDE WHAT THE
HOSPITALS HAVE SPENT ON
TREATMENT AND OTHER ISSUES.
WE HAD 11 BABIES BORN DURING
THIS INCIDENT, NUMEROUS CASES OF
COVID.
AND THOSE TYPES OF THINGS AND IT
PUTS A STRAIN.
THANKFULLY THE STATE SENT SOME
PEOPLE TO HELP.
STEVE: LET’S HOPE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CUTS YOU GUYS A
CHECK BECAUSE THEY OWE YOU
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT ENFORCING